翻訳: 広美 堀江
校正: Kayoko Shiomi
皆さんには夢はありますか
その夢はかないそうですか
私の夢は 異文化の理解に
つながるような記事を書く
ジャーナリストになることでした
私は 岡山県の県北の小さな町で育ち
大学生になるまで
外国の人や文化と接する機会が
ほとんどありませんでした
でも 広い世界への憧れがあり
異なる文化が出会う場所では
何かわくわくするような
新しいアイデアが生まれるのではないかと
想像していたんです
子供のころの性格は
内気で人見知りで
ジャーナリストに向いているとは
言えなかったと思います
でも 私には夢がありましたから
そんな自分をいくらでも
変えられると思えたし
勉強することは全て
自分の夢につながると考え
朝起きて学校に行くのが
待ち遠しい子供でした
そして誰もが 自分を取り巻く環境や
自分自身の性格を
夢に向かって変えていくことができると
信じていたんです
しかし 新聞記者になって２年目の時に
自分の力ではどうすることもできない
国際情勢の変化の中で
夢への道を阻まれる人たちがいる
ということを知りました
戦争によって
祖国の政治体制が変わったために
以前のように 仕事や生活ができなくなり
身一つでボートに乗って 祖国を出た
ベトナム難民の人々です
私は 当時 広島県の福山支局で
勤務していたのですが
福山市の沼隈町という町に
ベトナム難民の一時滞在施設がありました
施設は 県道から細い道に入り
しばらく進んだ
山の中にありました
そこには 難民という言葉から
イメージしていた
悲痛で 切羽詰まった雰囲気はなく
笑い声に包まれていたことさえありました
その中心にいたのが 黒川愛子さんでした
近くに住む主婦だった黒川さんは
２人のお子さんの子育てが終わるころに
このセンターで働き始め
指導員を経て 所長になられました
私がセンターの事務所を訪れると
難民の子供たちが よく
黒川さんに勉強を教わっていて
そこには 本当の家庭のような
温かな空気が流れていました
センターの難民たちは いつも笑顔で
私を迎えてくれました
でも 欧米諸国への定住を
希望していた難民たちの中には
希望の国に受け入れられるか
どうか分からず
センターでの滞在が数年にも及び
精神的に不安定になって
自殺騒ぎが起こる
というようなこともあったそうです
ベトナムからのボートピープルは
1975年から95年までの間に
13,768人 日本に到着しました
多くは 先に親類が定住し
支援体制も整った—
アメリカやカナダなどの国々での
定住を希望していました
しかし それまでたくさんの
難民を受け入れてきた これらの国々が
門戸を狭め始める中
希望の国に定住できるのか
それとも 日本に定住するのかが
決まるまでの間
日本国内に
多い時で20数カ所あった
民間の一時滞在施設で
難民たちは生活しました
私が訪れていた「日本赤十字広島県支部
ぬまくま救援センター」も
その一つでした
センターでは 77年からの17年間に
1,001人の難民たちが暮らしました
私は センターから
アメリカに渡った難民たちが
日本に対してどのような思いを抱き
どのように新たな人生を
歩み始めているのか
知りたいと思いました
そこで 追跡取材をすることにしたんです
フルブライト奨学金の支援を受け
カリフォルニア州の大学で学びながら
センターから旅立った難民たちを
アメリカ各地に訪ねました
センターでは
27人の赤ちゃんが生まれたのですが
この女の子は その１人です
96年当時 7歳になっていたこの女の子には
３つの名前が付けられていました
ベトナム語の「タオ」 英語の「ティナ」
そして日本語の「ハル」です
お父さんのヒューさんは
ベトナム 日本 アメリカという
３つの文化を忘れないでほしいから
と話してくれました
ベトナム語で日本を意味する「ニャット」
という名前が付けられた赤ちゃんも
多かったそうです
こちらの少年 クイ君には
彼が12歳の時
センターのクリスマスパーティーで
会ったことがありました
私がアメリカで取材した時には
17歳の高校生になっていました
クイ君とお母さんは
別々にベトナムを出た兄弟と
４年ぶりにアメリカで合流し
一緒に暮らすことができるように
なっていました
クイ君はアルバイトをして家計を支え
たった１つ自分のために買ったのは
日本語のテキストだと
話してくれました
私が アメリカで訪ねた難民たちは
政府の支援を受けながら昼間働き
夜 専門学校や短大に通って
目標としていたコンピューターや
美容系などの仕事に就いたばかりでした
子供たちは一生懸命に英語を勉強し
渡米からわずか２年で
地元の名門大学に入学したケースもあり
家族で支え合って 一生懸命
新しい生活を築こうとする姿が
印象的でした
留学の後 私は
外資系の通信社に移り
東京で勤務するようになりました
そして 2015年のある日
私のフェイスブックに
１通のメッセージが
アメリカから届いたんです
「あなたは 20年前に僕たちを訪ねてきた
ジャーナリストではありませんか」
クイ君からでした
初めて会った時 12歳だったクイ君は
37歳になって 郵便局で
働いているということでした
クイ君が 私のことを
覚えていてくれていて
探し出してくれたことが
とっても嬉しかったです
クイ君と同じボートで
ベトナムを脱出した110人は
マドンナ号という船に救助されたのですが
彼らは今 希望している国に定住し
それぞれの国で安定した生活を築き
自分たちを
「110マドンナグループ」と名付け
これまでの道のりを振り返り
資料を集め
助けてくれた人たちにあらためて感謝する
という取り組みを進めています
彼らを救助してくれた
マドンナ号の乗組員と船長は
フィリピン人の方々だったのですが
一言お礼を言いたいと
今も行方を捜しているのだそうです
こうして 難民たちとの
糸が再びつながり
私は20年ぶりに
黒川さんに連絡を取りました
そして 海外や国内に定住した難民たちが
沼隈町を懐かしんで
黒川さんのもとを訪れるようになり
黒川さんが
センターの跡地や町の周辺を
案内してあげている
ということを知ったんです
昨年来日した難民は 黒川さんに
ベトナムの民族衣装 アオザイを
プレゼントしました
この難民とはセンター出所以来
全く会っていないのに
細かな採寸を必要とするアオザイは
黒川さんにぴったりだったそうです
何年も前にお世話になった黒川さんの姿を
当時と同じように思い出すことが
できたんだと思います
この黒川さんと難民たちとの
30年に及ぶ交流は
私たちに２つのことを教えてくれます
１つは「夢や願いを共有して築いた絆は
その後の人生を支え続ける」ということです
難民問題は
祖国を出ざるを得なかった人々が
再び安住の地に落ち着き
家族と共に平穏な日々を取り戻して
初めて解決に向かいます
しかし 自分や子供の将来に希望を抱き
夢に向かって生きていける
そんな 平和な社会では当たり前の
環境が整うまでには
長い年月がかかるのです
黒川さんと難民たちが
センターで過ごした期間は
長くても数年です
しかし 黒川さんの
難民たちに寄り添う気持ち
その気持ちに感謝する心が積み重なり
センターを出た後の長い年月を経ても
絆は続いていきました
この交流が私たちに教えてくれること
２つ目は「夢や願いを共有できれば
言葉や文化の違いは大きなハードル
にはならない」ということです
「言葉は通じなくても
誠心誠意 接すれば
思いは通じるんですよ」
と黒川さんは言います
センターで自殺騒ぎがあった時
夜中に駆け付け
難民の気持ちが落ち着くまで
そばに寄り添う
というようなこともあったそうです
飛行機が空を飛んでいるのを見たら
「乗せられるものなら
今すぐにでも
あの飛行機に乗せて
希望の国に行かせてあげたい」
そう思ったそうです
「この人たちの願いを
どうかかなえてあげたい その一心だった」と
難民たちと過ごした日々を振り返ります
現在 紛争や迫害のために
祖国を追われた人々の数は
6,560万人に上ります
日本の人口の約半数です
皆さんの２人に１人が
今この瞬間 難民です
そして その半数が子供です
私は 子供たちが夢を抱き
夢の実現に向かって努力するということが
自分の力ではどうすることもできない理由で
阻まれる世界であってはならないと思います
そんな過酷な環境が生まれないように
紛争を解決し
国際情勢が安定することも重要です
しかし もし難民という境遇に
なってしまった場合に
黒川さんのように 夢や願いに
寄り添ってくれた人がいる という事実は
子供たちの将来にとって
大切な支えになるのです
私にとって この取材の始まりは
「センターの難民の現状を知りたい」
という素朴な思いでした
そこから踏み出した一歩が
この日本と難民の定住国とにまたがる
壮大なストーリーへと
つながっていったんです
まずは「関心を持ち 行動を起こすこと」
それが 異文化理解の第一歩です
さて ジャーナリストになって
四半世紀が経ち
私の夢はかなったのかというと
かなったという感覚はありません
仕事にはゴールがなく
「次はこうしよう」と思うことの連続です
最近は
夢がかなったと実感することは
もうずっとないのかもしれない
と思うこともあります
でも クイさんがアメリカの地で
20年もの間
私が書いた記事を
大切に持っていてくれたことは
私にとって 大きな支えになっています
そして 黒川さんと難民たちとの
このまさに「世界をつなぐ物語」を
今こうして 皆さんにお伝えできたことで
私の夢は ほんの少し
実現に近づいたのかもしれない
と思っています
ありがとうございました
(拍手）
（司会）堀江さん
ありがとうございました
今日は—
（堀江広美）今日は 黒川さんと
日本赤十字国際部の田中康夫さんが
会場にいらしてくれていますので
ご紹介したいと思います
どうぞ
（拍手）
きょうは黒川さんは広島の方から
早朝においでくださって
田中さんは なんと
昨日までバングラデシュで
ロヒンギャ難民の救援に携わって
いらっしゃったということで
本当にお忙しい中 来てくださって
ありがとうございます
（拍手）
（司会）よかったら一言お願いします
（黒川さん）感動してものが言えません
すみません でも
沼隈をふるさとに旅立った人たちが
みなさん幸せでありますように
心からいつも願っております
（拍手）
（堀江）今日 アオザイを
持ってきてくださいました
（笑）
（拍手）
（田中さん）黒川さんは難民たちから
「お母さん」と呼ばれてまして
先ほど お話がありましたように
「Mutual Respect」それから
「Trust」という言葉が
まさにぴったりな人だと思います
生半可な事では 他の人に対して
「お母さん」という言葉は
使わないと思うんですね
そういうスタッフと一緒に仕事ができたことは
私はとても誇りですし
従来 アフリカ他 いろんなところで
活動してまいりましたが
この黒川さんと一緒に働いた—
日本でのベトナム難民(救済)の
仕事と言うのは
私の今の一番の軸になっています
ベトナム難民は
1975年4月30日にサイゴンが陥落して
２週間もたたない5月13日に
最初の難民が日本に来ました
今 赤十字でこれまで数ヶ月の間で
120人のスタッフが
現地で活動しているわけですが
一番難しいのが
支援がなかなか集まらない
つまり 無関心ということです
「人道の敵は無関心」と
われわれ考えておりまして
ぜひ 今日のこういった話を契機に
日本で難民問題があったということを
もう１回思い出していただいて
関心が広がればと思います
ありがとうございます
（拍手）
（司会）お二人ともありがとうございました
（司会）それでは あらためまして
堀江さん ありがとうございました
（拍手）